Thank you. Here comes the answer.
The answer, of course, is you put the part back in,
and you try to remove other parts. Why is that so?
Well, if you remember our discussion of the scientific method in the first unit,
what you just had is you set up a hypothesis on why the failure occurred.
You removed some part, and you observed that after removing this part,
your hypothesis on what the failure is no longer holds,
so you go back to your earlier hypothesis and remove other parts.
Trying to keep only the part and remove everything else makes little sense,
and keep on removing until the failure occurs again also is very unlikely to happen.